Es war eine gigantische Asteroidenexplosion.
Die Explosion hatte die 10fache Stärke der
Atombombe von Hiroshima.
Wäre dieser Brocken in einer Stadt niedergegangen
wäre sie zerstört worden.
Alle Einwohner wären umgekommen.
Oder noch schlimmer: Er wäre in die Behringsee
gestürzt.
Warum das so ist: Alle Infos jetzt in Clixoom
Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich spannende
Sciencevideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht’s.
Herzlich wilkommen!
Ich habe es immer gesagt und oft wurde mir
Panikmache vorgeworfen, aber ständig schlagen
riesige Asteroiden auf der Erde ein oder explodieren
in der Atmosphäre.
Tscheljabinsk 2013 war die letzte große Explosion
und jetzt schon wieder.
Damals wurden rund 7000 Gebäude beschädigt
und 1500 Menschen verletzt.
Die Sprengkraft jetzt 173 Kilotonnen, das
10fache der Hiroshimabombe.
Durchmesser wahrscheinlich zehn Meter, Geschwindigkeit
unfassliche 115.200 Kilometer pro Stunde.
Und nur weil der Asteroid etwas mehr als 25
Kilometer über der menschenleeren Behringsee
explodiert ist, kam niemand zu schaden.
Es handelt sich um die zweitschwerste derartige
Explosion in diesem Jahrhundert.
Das ganze geschah bereits im Dezember.
Niemand hatte es bemerkt.
Und das zeigt auch auf, dass selbst Megaexplosionen
niemand auffallen.
Riesige Regionen sind einfach unbewohnt oder
einfach Meer, wie rund 70 Prozent der Erde.
Selbst große Einschläge fallen dort nicht
auf.
Und aufgrund der zentrischen Wellenentstehung
gibt es auch keine großen Tsunamis, wie wir
hier letztlich berichtet haben.
Da der Einschlag punktförmig ist, verlieren
sie ihre Energie sehr schnell und sind ab
einer Entfernung des Einschlags von mehr als
20 Kilometern mit aller Wahrscheinlichkeit
gar nicht mehr gefährlich.
Etwas ganz anderes könnte die furchtbare
Konsequenz sein.
Mehrer hundert Megatonnen Wasser werden durch
den Einschlag bis in die Stratosphäre katapultiert.
Ein Teil davon sehr schnell über den Eintrittsweg
des Asteroiden, weil er hier ein Teilvakuum
zurückgelassen hat, dass jetzt das Wasser
ansaugt.
In der Stratosphäre kann das Wasser dann
Monate oder Jahre verbleiben und heizt dann
den Treibhauseffekt auf der Erde weiter an.
Das wäre die schlimmste Katastrophe und könnte
zu Millionen Toten führen.
Sprich: Ein Einschlag direkt in eine Millionenstadt
wäre zwar verheerend und würde sie wahrscheinlich
wie eine Atombombe vernichten.
Ein Einschlag in einen Ozean aber könnte
weitaus verheerender sein, weil er Auswirkungen
auf die ganze Erde haben würde!
Und eins wird durch diese Explosion klar:
Wir sind einem Asteroidendauerregen ausgesetzt.
Und wenn man sich dann die Karte der NASA
ansieht mit den größeren Asteroiden, die
in die Erdatmosphäre eingedrungen sind, dann
bekommt man schon ein wenig Bammel wie viele
das sind und man sieht, dass die aktuelle
Explosion wirklich mit der Explosion über
Tscheljabinsk zu den beiden größten gehört,
die bisher festgestellt wurden.
Wahnsinn!
Und es zeigt auf wie dringend wir etwas gegen
Asteroiden tun müssen.
Und die Nasa wird jetzt aktiv: Premiere: NASA
will Asteroiden aus der Bahn werfen!
Dafür hier klicken, anschauen und Abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!